هذا اللقاء طلب طلب من الجانب الامريكي
ارسال ثلاث محامين وارسلت نيابه عني لما
انت لا كان يعني
بعد ان
صدر حكم الاعدام
وراها بقينا بالمنطق خضراء
اسبوع كامل او اكثر من اسبوع يعني تقريبا
عشره ايام الى ان نقلونا الطائره امريكيه
تابعه للبنتاجون الى المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه حتى بدون ختم جوازات
الجانب الامريكي الضابط الامريكي المسؤول
عن يعني حمايتنا مسؤول مكتب الارتباط
جمعنا واعطى محاضره طويله عريضه يعني انه
قدمته كل
وما قصرتوا وبالاخير التفت علي قال وانت
يا استاذ خليل واثنى كلام طويل على دوري
وعلى اخلاص الرئيس وعلى يعني اعتزاز
الرئيسيه فقال لي من اعتبارا من اليوم
احنا حميناك حتى اجسادنا وحمايه قضائيه
وحمايه امنيه حمايه شخصيه من الان فصاعدا
لا نستطيع توفير الحمايه القضائيه من اي
يعني طلب عليك قضائي
او يعني
قضيه يعني ضدي ولكن نستطيع ان نحميك كان
مرفوع قضايا ضدك او كان عادي يعني بسيطه
كانوا يرفعوا قضايا ضدك بكل بساطه تمام كل
بساطه
ما الذي ذكره الرئيس الاسبق صدام حسين
للمحامين الثلاثه في اللقاء الاخير الذي
لم تحضره ثلاث مرات يعني اقدم على القدوم
ويمنعني الجانب الامريكي ويمنع احد زملائي
ايضا هو نائب رئيس الدفاع
يعني منعه من زياره موكله كان وكيل
المرحوم في رمضان
فمنتصل بالجانب الامريكي وبعثت الزملاء
والتقوا ويا مع الرئيس
ابلغوه بالمصادق على حكم الاعدام
فاكدوا لهم انه اني انتظر هذا اليوم وانا
متوقعه ودائما كان يقدرنا انه اني طلقت
الحياه من عام 1959 عندما ضربت عبد الكريم
قاسم انا ايضا حكمت بالاعدام ومحكوم عده
مرات بالاعدام فما بالتاس يعني استقبل
الموضوع برحابه صدر وبعد فيها برساله يعني
للشعب العراقي هي يعني رساله وداع ووصيه
بنفس الوقت انه لا تحقدوا
الشعب الامريكي ولا الشعوب اللي اللي اجت
وغزتنا لكن الحقد او الكراهيه تكون
لقادتهم هم اللي سبب اللقاء الاخير مع
المحامين قبل ايضا هل عرض على صدام حسين
تناول مهدئات بعد صدور الحكم نعم وكان
يرفض يعني كان يرفضات رجل يعني مؤمن بقدره
ومؤمن مصيره وكان يعني الاخر لحظه يعني
شجاع وما يحتاج يعني اني انه يعني
امدحه
بالمحكمه شجاع وموقف الشجاع
وبالاخر لحظه